i took a lot of heat for being the only
republican in the senate to vote no
on what was called the the
asian-american hate crime bill was
senator hirono's bill
this is a few weeks ago the reason i
voted no is because it didn't have
anything to do with with hate crimes
those are already illegal
it gave the department of justice the
power to define of
hate incidents which is offensive speech
so it gives the government the power to
decide well this speech is offensive
that speech is offensive and then it it
gives doj the power to help
states and local governments track it
and monitor it and create a database i
was like this is crazy
i mean this is this is a first major
first amendment problems here
so i'm against hate crimes but i'm not
i'm not for the government
uh censoring and defining and tracking
speech for heaven's sake so
this kind of thing is becoming more and
more common and we need
conservatives and constitutionalists to
call it out to stand up and
have the courage of their convictions
yeah so since you do care about that old
piece of paper that
set up this country i thought maybe you
could explain i
talk about it a lot on the show but i i
think you'll be able to
uh explain it pretty clearly the
difference the sort of guarantee of the
constitution of equality
versus what the left is now pushing on
us which is equity
well listen i mean the equality
guarantee is that as citizens
we have the same rights to stand before
the law
and to participate in our democracy as
any other citizen does
and this is the country is is founded on
on this premise
in many ways and this is sort of our
core bedrock guarantee that
you know you don't have to be born to a
certain family or born in a certain zip
code or have a certain amount of wealth
in order to matter in this country
and we think that every person matters i
look back to you know thomas jefferson
has this great
phrase where he says that cultivators of
the earth you know farmers
are the most valuable of citizens now i
come from a farming family so
i heard that a lot growing up and i i
tend to i tend to agree with it
but it was revolutionary statement at
jefferson's time because you know if you
look back in human history
people who worked with their hands were
usually dismissed you know i was like oh
i mean that's manual labor that's for
people who can't get educated
who aren't smart and the idea that
manual laborers would have a role would
be a citizen
and would have a role in democrat i mean
absolutely not yeah the romans for
instance the greeks they would never
have allowed that
our country is premised on the idea that
folks who who work for a living are
valuable and that everybody should stand
as an equal before the law
and it's the law that should rule the
law made by the people and not
not any particular person or group of
people so that is
that is a long answer i guess to what i
think our constitution our core
constitutional commitment is
what the left wants though now is
identity politics i mean what they want
to say is is that they want to define
this group that group they want to put
americans they want to divvy us up by
race they want to divvy us up by
identities that they will construct that
the left will construct they'll tell us
which identities are legitimate and
which not
and they want to divvy us up along those
lines and they want to pit one group
against another
and that's what they are doing that's
what a lot of this woke agenda is that's
what a lot of this critical race theory
agenda really and movement really
amounts to and uh
that i i would submit to you is severely
damaging
to the kind of equality that the
constitution actually guarantees
have you seen this bill i think it's
just circulating in the last little bit
this
it has something to do with the coveted
relief bill where they are actually
going to help
farmers of color before they help white
farmers
have you heard about this yeah yeah in
fact that's law i mean that's exactly
that's
oh it actually is the llano i mean it is
the law of the land yes it is the law of
the land
what do we do what do we do systemic
racism is here
yeah yeah oh it's i mean it's it's it's
here and and in force
absolutely it was in the last coven
relief bill and i tell you this stuff is
it's just really extraordinary
uh you know i i took a lot of heat for
being the only republican
in the senate to vote no on what was
called the the asian-american hate crime
bill was senator hirono's bill
this is a few weeks ago the reason i
voted no is because it didn't have
anything to do with with hate crimes
those are already illegal
it gave the department of justice the
power to define a
hate incident which is offensive speech
so it gives the government the power to
decide well this speech is offensive
that speech is offensive and then it it
gives doj the power to help
states and local governments track it
and monitor it and create a database i
was like this is crazy
i mean this is this is a first major
first amendment problems here
so i'm against hate crimes but i'm not
i'm not for the government
uh censoring and defining and tracking
speech for heaven's sake
so this kind of thing is becoming more
and more common and we need
conservatives and constitutionalists to
call it out to stand up and
have the courage of their convictions do
you think the legal system is the only
thing that fixes that like to me
that being a part of the package as
you're saying and it is law now i mean
there there i actually i just heard just
this morning that there is a farmer
who is now going to sue so i guess i and
i must have in fact known that it had
been passed
but there is a white farmer who's going
to sue because he is not by the color of
his skin
going to get the same relief as another
farmer because of the color
of their skin is the only recourse
really that it has to get to the courts
and then basically we have to pray
that the courts do the right thing i
think it is now for that package once it
becomes law
you know i mean then then the only
recourse you have left
is to try to go to the courts and to try
to rely on the constitution and defend
your rights and
you know look i'm i'm a constitutional
lawyer by trade i was a prosecutor in
the state of missouri
as attorney general and so i i'm
certainly not averse to going to the
courts
but i will say this that it would be
much much better
if we actually stopped these kind of
destructive policies from becoming law
in the first place
if we actually stopped the woke agenda
from getting enacted into law
and we need more folks who are willing
to stand up and do that and i think
right now there's a real sentiment of
well we just have to kind of go along
in washington dc we don't have to go
along it doesn't have to be like this we
can present a credible alternative
and we can make the case for the core
principles of our constitution and we
need to
do you think part of this is just that a
certain set of republicans kind of want
to be liked
they just you know the sort of mitt
romney liz cheney
that's that battle that's happening now
where it's sort of the media loves
these people that only years ago they
were telling everyone that mitt romney's
racist because he was running against
barack obama
but now he's a hero because he's sort of
against
say trump or you or ted cruz something
like that the guys who are actually
doing something but they're i keep
calling them the pet republicans because
they can get
people on msnbc to say nice things about
them i do think that the media has
really invested the legacy media
establishment
media the leftists are really invested
in this idea of a republican civil war
and so they really want to create
conflict and play it up between uh
establishment to republicans
and uh and conservatives or populist
republicans i can just tell you
from being home in the state of missouri
and talking to actual people you know i
mean actual voters
they have no interest in a republican
civil war there is no such thing they
made up their mind they're like what's
the conflict
i mean they don't want to go back to
open borders
and to ruinous trade policies and to
liberal globalism they don't want to go
back to that at all so they're like
what what's the conflict you're talking
about no no no they want to go forward
they want to know what we're going to do
to stop this radical left woke agenda
that president biden is trying to force
down our throats is trying to ramrod
through the senate i mean
and then they want to know going forward
what we're going to do to actually
defend our constitution to actually get
jobs back in this country manufacturing
back in this country
and and give working people a voice
again that's what they want to know
about and
you know i think that this media
narrative that you're pointing to
or talking about it's just it's it's
false and it's meant to distract from
where people
really are so what should the messaging
be i mean i guess that's sort of what
you're saying
what should the messaging be for
republicans going forward because i feel
like it's still
you know nobody really knows who's in
charge is this trump's party still is it
going some other
way like what do you think that
messaging looks like well i think we
ought to listen to our voters i think
what our voters want is they want us to
be a pro-worker family a
pro-worker a party rather that we are
four working americans that we are going
to work
to get good jobs that pay good wages for
folks right where they are that you
shouldn't have to move to a foreign
country
in order to get a good job that you
shouldn't have to move halfway around
the country to get a good job we need to
be
the party of working people we need to
be the party of families you know we
need to be out there fighting for
families to be able
to afford to start a family and to raise
a family and by the way
to be able to make their own decisions
about their family i talk about this in
the book big tech shouldn't raise our
kids
we should raise our kids and american
families want to have the authority and
the power to raise their kids and tell
big tech get out of my life
i want to raise my own children so i
think as a party who are we we're the
party of working america
we're the party of working families in
this country
and we need to be advancing an agenda
that's pro-worker and pro-family i think
that is our future
as a party if it's not i mean if if
republicans are not willing
to be to be the party of working people
and to be the party of working families
then we're not going to have a future as
a party i mean it's just that simple
that
that is who our voters are and if we're
not going to be responsive to them
if we're going to be the party of wall
street or if we're going to be the party
of the globalist we're not going to have
a party
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell